all right so welcome this is lecture 21
of
1413 we're going to talk about poverty
as seen through the lens of
psychology uh what are we going to do
i'm going to give you some broad
overview we're going to particularly
talk about this work on
scarcity by mani rao which is the idea
that
um thinking your thoughts about poverty
captures people's minds which in turn
leaves less capacity
in people's minds to do other things and
then we're going to talk a little bit
uh at the end at least briefly about
other deprivations that poverty entails
um some of this is work that i have done
some of this is worked by others
okay so i want to start with like a
simple observation that i sort of like
at the heart of um
a lot of this literature and the
observation is that
um when you look around um in the world
and look for evidence and when you work
on
poverty related issues you'll see um
observe quite a few um seemingly
suboptimal behaviors
among the poor this would be things like
lack of investment or taking advantage
of high return investment opportunities
this would be like investment in
fertilizer or
health investments or machines or
like um or like low savings
in particular things like precautionary
savings like being ready for shocks
saving for the future for the retirement
and so on
at the same time with high return uh or
high
interest rate um credit people take very
high
interest loans in part what i've shown
you
earlier in the class that's particularly
prevalent among the poor
there's some evidence of like um worse
performance
of parenting among poor parents
including like things like violence
against children and so on
there's some evidence of lower
productivity
punctuality lower medical adherence
for like you know drugs that are sort of
even very high-stakes drugs that are
life-saving
there's some evidence of food and drug
consumption
in terms of like uh healthy eating or um
excessive um drug use and the like all
of those things
tend to be correlated one other way the
other with different forms of
income or poverty okay and so now
you might sort of say well that's
interesting but now what explains these
behaviors
how do we think about this what a
plausible explanation
kinds of correlations to be very clear
these are correlations
um uh not causal effects
so education could explain quite a few
of those things could explain
potentially productivity it could
explain potentially
um parenting and to explain some form of
like
um financial investments they could also
explain things like medical adherence
like for example if you look at
um in
some settings where people have not
sort of learned in school any basics of
medicine or biology and so on and sort
of then it's not obvious that you should
take
medicine from the traditional doctor
versus from some healer in the village
because you know how would you know
what's better and what's worse instead
of presumably some of these things you
would learn
um in school so one broad explanatory
factor is sort of like omitted variables
if you went on one of them
is potentially education it's not about
like
um committed variable this is about like
um
a treatment effect of poverty itself um
and i'm gonna be more specific about
that but essentially something about
like
being in poverty itself uh affects
people's behaviors that causes them
um uh some of these outcomes some of
these things that we've seen here we've
talked about that in
detail but that's exactly right i mean
in some ways like people would say
even for um like if you take credit for
example or for some things you know
you probably can't explain but for high
return investment you would say wow
there's uncertainty and there's a good
chance that there might be losses at the
end of the day
and if you're really close to
subsistence you might not want to invest
in stuff because you know
um if a bad shock happens um that's
really bad
um so i think some of that is right in
punctuality punctuality for example
could
could also be in some way uncertainty is
like you tried to take a bus to work and
the bus just comes every
hour and then sometimes this comes a
half an hour earlier and sometimes comes
later and it's really hard to be
actually
punctual it could just be like people
some people are not productive and
they're just bad at doing stuff
and therefore um they become poorer and
then they end up being poor
because of that so that's essentially i
think that we covered pretty much
everything so one is
it could be sort of environmental
conditions which is you know
transportation
it's really hard to get to work on time
or like you have to communicate for two
hours and then you're really tired and
that makes you less productive
things like predatory lending sort of
tricks you want to like lending
there could be some things about
institutional structures which is to say
like you know i told you for example at
mit
um there's a default um what other
places there's
defaults for people to save money and
there's a default to like get health
insurance and there's defaults for all
sorts of like good behaviors
like you know um uh uh
for vaccinations and so on and so forth
where you sort of like essentially
pushed by society
about the environmental conditions that
you face into doing the right thing
or whatever good behaviors whatever you
want to call it and so
um um and so the poor might just not
have those things so for example having
a bank account
might be like if you paid um daily or
you can buy like trick the rich
by trip the big shot drivers that i was
showing you earlier in the semester
they paid trip by trip and then they
passed by like the liquor stores
uh uh essentially daily and have a bunch
of cash on hand
well that's much trickier to sort of
resist in some sense if you were
um particularly also prone to physical
pain and then sort of uh
to use alcohol as a way to deal with
your physical pain
as opposed to somebody who's paid months
late and half of the money goes into
like the rent
anyway and like on other expenses and so
on which is much easier to
to manage so that's kind of like broadly
i haven't summarized it as like
environmental conditions then there's
like selection and
emitted variables which is them i think
jose was mentioning education which is a
very good one
there's things like um intelligence
talent
effort mistakes and so on you might say
well like if you are
um more prone if you're less productive
for example if you're prone to making
mistakes and so on
well that sort of um leads to worse
outcome and that means you end up
um being poor and that's really like
sort of like uh
uh in some sense like a right-wing kind
of you that said like you know people
are
they should do whatever they want to do
and like if they end up being poor it's
sort of their fault
and so on that's of course not what
we're going to argue um here will be
interested in or what i'm trying to
show you some evidence stuff is that
there's a treatment effect of poverty
um itself potentially which is to say
that like being poor itself
causes these behaviors and i'm going to
show you evidence of like two
uh and two ways one is
um by inducing thoughts about money
essentially thinking about can you pay
school fees can you pay your rent can
you get groceries for your children are
your children going to be hungry tonight
and so on
these are all kind of thoughts that
invade people's minds involved
voluntarily and by doing so um they
capture
people's attention and then since
attention overall is limited
and people have less attention available
for other things
that sort of one broad um um
theory um and i'll focus on that mostly
which sort of because people call it
people refer to under the name of
scarcity and and then you know there's a
bunch of other
aspects of poverty as well that might be
uh impeding with people's cognitive
function their attention
that tire them out which is like not
sleeping well being in pain
um being exposed to pollution
environmental pollution
uh noise pollution and so on
and so forth and so now what's the
underlying
sort of idea here while again the lying
idea is that there might be a
what's called like people call it
behavioral poverty drought
trap and the broad line of argument is
that poverty affects people's
cognition decision making of
productivity these factors in turn
then influence people's future uh
poverty because if you're not productive
and you can't save money and so on
you're going to be
more poor in the future and then if
those things are going on there's
essentially some form of vicious
cycle going on which makes it difficult
if not
um impossible for a person to become
rich now notice at the very least that
will lower
mobility you know sometimes you're poor
and you want to become richer you have
to deal with a bunch of bad stuff that
happens to you um
every day um but my conscious human
mobility is low it might or it might be
like actually a trap it's just
next to or actually impossible to become
richer because all these forces are too
strong to
overcome them for people um so today
we're going to talk about two
broad lines of research i'm going to
first focus mostly on the first one
which is monitoring concerns capture
people's cognitive function
i'm going to talk a little bit then
about other poverty-induced depression
and behaviors which might have sort of
similar effects
um overall okay so now i want to
do like a simple um uh test with you um
so what i'd like you to do is to um
so i don't second actually
ready don't write anything down just try
to remember it and then uh try to recall
in a bit
okay i'm gonna start reading bed
rest dream doze
snore slumber blanket
snooze wake map
awake tired
okay now please write down the as many
words as you
remember
ten more seconds
all right so done so um uh usually i
would sort of like have people raise
their hands which is a little tricky but
so i'm gonna just read you the list of
words and you can knock to me i couldn't
see some of you at least uh you cannot
and
tell me whether you remember um um
the the words that i read
okay i'm gonna start bed
rest pretty good
green doze
snore oh
slumber
sleep
blanket snooze
quake nap
awake tired
okay so i know this is making everybody
sleepy and want to take a nap um
me too um so here's a list of words um
um that
asked me to remember now um one thing
that's kind of nice
you and me you know like most people
remember quite a few things um um
and the majority for example remember
sped and so on and so forth
now what's quite interesting about these
words is that
um while i remember i put all these
names up here which is you know
um these are the words that i actually
read now one word that's actually
missing in this list here
is sleep and so um
you sort of i snuck this in here i'm
uh this is why i had to go back um it
turns out i actually didn't read the
word sleep
now quite a few of you were nodding i'm
happily when i asked you about sleep
and what's the reason why sleep is why
you remembered sleep
so all of these words is like uh um
they they all around sleep so like it's
really like
uh uh sleep should have been there
it's kind of the type of thing where
people would ask you like have you been
to the party
last week where like people just assumed
where essentially all the friends were
there people just assumed that you were
there as well because you're supposed to
be there
it's like sleep is supposed to be in
this list but he didn't put it there and
sort of
this is what called like false memory
tests and there's quite a bit of work on
actually false memories and people's
minds essentially make up things
um in particular stuff that sort of um
or where you have all situations that
that
you think that should be the case you
can do the same with like man
and other lists and so on and now
psychologists have been
doing like um studies um for the rich
and the poor and so
here's two lists one is about sort of
money related stuff
and one is about uh sort of just
anything that's related to like i guess
man or like um gender in some ways and i
looked at how many people have certain
false memories
and what these studies show it's
essentially that when you look when you
take this list for a man
can you do this with high and poor high
income and low income
people the fraction who remember man
wrong way
um is about like you know 15 to 20 um
the fraction among the poor who remember
money is similarly high among the rich
that's not the case now why is that well
it seems to be that like for the poor
when you read lists like groceries
expense spill gas etc
what they think about is essentially how
i'm going to pay for this and they think
about
money when um for the rich and
instead when you say like groceries or
whatever they think about like what i'm
going to buy for dinner and what are the
nice things i'm going to do
and for them this is really not top of
mind so this is essentially
at least one piece of evidence that
money captures
um the minds of the poor more so than
for the rich now
a second study is a study about their
doctor's visit
so this is a study where they uh
participants were asked about following
situation which is
imagine that you have been feeling sick
lately and finally decide to go see a
doctor about it
the doctor explains to have a serious
condition that requires immediate
attention
the good news however is you are
virtually guaranteed to make a full
recovery
the doctor writes several prescriptions
you will also need to make several
appointments what would be on your mind
on or or how would you feel about when
you hear this news
what are the three things that you think
about it or
feel you can think about for a second
what is it that you would feel what are
you thinking about when you when you see
this
and what's particularly interesting is
now when you look at people's responses
some people say wife son co-worker
uh uh some people are scared afraid
worried
um relief hope joy so like emotions
um uh uh or just relationships and other
people
not exactly sure what the co-worker is
doing there but anyway um
uh uh but um what's particularly
interesting is like the fraction of
people who say
costs and as you can imagine um
when you do this by low and high income
um when you think about like
um medical conditions
for the rich um this is much more about
like emotions about
about their health about like their
relationships their loved ones and so on
when the poor think about like health or
health expenditures or health issues
they think very much about health
expenditures and that is essentially
what's top of mind
for them and so again when you split the
sample by low and high income people
the poor have much higher proportions of
money related thoughts
as reported by these kinds of questions
compared to the rich
the third study um last study that i'm
going to show you is the study that i
showed you very much at the beginning of
the class which was study about
um imagine you are about to purchase an
ipad for 500. the salesman says
you can get the same ipad exact same
ipod for 15
off would you walk for uh uh 30 minutes
in total for for doing it would you go
for the other store
and similarly you should do the same
thing for an ipad case
and sort of the result that we found in
this class and like but other studies
have found is that
people are way more likely to report
than they would walk for the ipad case
than for the ipad itself and the
explanation of course is
um that people evaluate things in
relative terms
right so if you think about the ipad
case 15 is like
really high relative to like 30 dollars
the ipad cases um value
well um for the ipad itself 15 compared
to 500
is like not very much now that's in some
sense some form of like money illusion
or some form of
unit confusion of the leg because at the
end of the day
you should just be willing to walk for
30 minutes for either 15
or not that's not gonna change depending
on whether you buy an ipad or an ipad
case now many studies have found this
kind of patterns including like in this
class
but once you do that with the poor then
much less likely if at all to engage in
this kind of behavior
which seems to sort of suggest that the
poor in fact are less prone to these
kind of
labeling or sort of like monetary um uh
sort of um
comparisons um for them essentially a
dollar is a dollar and they sort of
understand that like 15
is valuable regardless of like what is
surrounding comparisons
um might be and so if i had to summarize
now what i've just shown you very
quickly is that
thoughts about money um tend to capture
and
take much more space in the poor's minds
these are the first two studies that
showed you
that i showed you and second the extra
focus on money has actually some
positive consequences in some sense
in some sense you can say here this is
an irrational decision to say
um yes that you will do it for the ipad
case compared to like the ipad or
sort of there's some mis-optimization
going on so the poor actually doing
better they're less prone to these kinds
of errors
um um compared to the rich i think
that's a good thing people like
better potentially better monetary
decisions here
um so there's some positive um
consequences or um
uh impacts based on that but now um
and this is we're gonna go as well are
there also some negative effects
potentially
the reason being that um if you have a
certain amount of attention available
overall or cognitive resources available
if your brain is taking out by
essentially um
these thoughts about money then um there
will be less available resources for
other stuff any questions on
on this so far
okay so then um let's talk about the
um uh scarcity work specifically so
scarcity is actually defined
generally here as not having enough
enough of something
this could be money friends hair uh time
etc it's very general actually
um and so the idea is just like if you
have something that you think you don't
have enough
notice that the definition is pretty
vague in the sense of like
it's not just saying like having low
income but instead of
thinking that you don't have enough
income which could be also like in
relative terms and so on
and then yet the the hypothesis is that
scarcity capture people's
mental cognitive capacity their
bandwidth as they call it
this happens automatically and not
intentionally that is to say that it's
not people
choose to spend a lot of time on uh
thinking about money
but rather um money captures their minds
and then they have trouble thinking
about other uh
things think about this inside would be
like suppose you have like some
fights with a good friend of yours or a
partner or the leg
and then you have an important job
interview it's really not productive to
think about the fight with your
um a friend or
family member or partner or the like
during the job interview there's nothing
productive about doing that you should
be focusing on the interview and try to
do your best
but it might be that like essentially
these thoughts invade your minds and you
sort of
get really distracted unintentionally
and then do worse in those kinds of
things
and that's the idea here uh similarly
here as well
which is um that essentially um there's
might be some benefit of like
figuring out monitoring problems and
figuring out how to pay the bills and so
on and so forth
but overall um these benefits might be
overwhelmed by
um taking over people's brain
that leaves less resources for other
things
um the decisions that are productivity
that people have to do in life
and so uh in particular poverty now so
this is a general introduction now
poverty specifically makes monetary
concerns
top of mind today they poor might be
acting more rational in some ways
in some sense in financial choices which
is kind of what that
the evidence that i just showed you and
there are several studies to try to make
that point
um but you know scarcity might then
deteriorate performance at other
cognitive tasks
now here's sort of a powerpoint version
of that which is you know people may
think about many things in life they
might think about rent they might think
about
the kids doing well eating healthy
utilities uh car payments and so on but
what does scarcity do it magnifies
essentially people's thoughts about rent
car
payments and utility bills he's all
monetary things that people think about
a lot
and then it might sort of like drown out
or like force out other thoughts about
other things about eating healthy
or about uh taking care of their kids in
other
ways than paying the bills okay
and so now i'm going to show you
evidence from two studies that sort of
support this point the first one is
um or the paper is called poverty and
pete's cognitive function that was the
reading for today
the first one is called them all the
study so what does a small study do it's
a
kind of like a lab experiment but it's
sort of in some sense like a field
experiment
uh uh so it's in a new jersey mall that
um asks shoppers or stops shoppers um
with the median
uh household income of roughly 70 000
um to someone richer than the average
american
but with quite a bit of um range of
income uh overall so they select very
rich people unfairly um poor people
and then um there's a sequence of um
three events essentially which is
um people are asked hypothetical
questions involving money
some are hard and some are easy and then
people are asked to do cognitive tests
these are non-verbal
tests that sort of measure people's
fluid intelligence which is raven's
matrices which you might be um familiar
with just with iq type
tests and some form of cognitive control
which essentially is about like are you
able to override
um automatic responses um when making uh
when doing cognitive tasks and then uh
number three then is like
people then answer the hypothetical
questions so what does this look like
the hypothetical question is involving
money
which is the following your car is
having some trouble and requires x
dollars to be fixed
you can pay in full um take a loan or
take a chance and forgo the service at
the moment
how would you go about making this
decision and so then that people ask
this question and they say well you can
think about this for a while and then
afterwards i'm going to ask you
um about the answer of that question and
then
there's a hard version and an easy
version
the idea is that the experiment wants to
keep everything
the same for like uh across treatments
and the idea that that is that 150 for
the average american is not that much
money so it's
not going to be like a huge problem for
most people at least in normal times of
their lives
but fifteen hundred dollars is actually
a lot of money for like a low-income
person in the us
but perhaps not that um big of a deal
for rich perks
like for rich person the 1500 or the 150
are both fine they're going to have some
money in the bank account and they're
going to deal with it somehow it's not a
huge issue
for the poor person 150 is you know
not great but not a huge problem or not
a huge headache but fifteen hundred
dollars surely is really bad
that's sort of the idea here and varying
um uh this
now what uh the study then finds is that
and
let me walk you through these graphs
let's look on the left side um
on the right side is quite similar
you'll see here
um always four bars the bars are
um for the dark bars are how people are
doing after the hard task and the
um the lighter bus bars are after the
easy task
let's um start with the light gray bars
comparing the poor versus the rich and
what you essentially see is the poor and
the rich are doing pretty much the same
after doing um the easy task so to be
clear what's poor versus which is
essentially medium split
by the median income so if you're above
the medium you're called
rich if you're below the medium you're
called poor for the purpose of this
study
now um for the
for the easy task here this is like the
rich do essentially as well or as badly
as
the poor do they get about forty percent
uh uh
cracked in these these um uh ravens uh
puzzles and the poor do essentially the
same so there's no difference after the
easy task
now after the hard task for the rich
essentially it's the same if anything
they do a little bit better
the this difference is not statistically
significant
in contrast you see like a clear drop in
uh performance among the poor okay they
do about like
um uh uh twelve percentage points worse
this is like really like a huge
difference
in how well people um so this is for
raymond's matrices this is for
um what's called hearts and flowers for
cognitive control which is essentially
how good are people
at uh controlling their attentional
resources and what you see is
essentially more or less the same
pattern
that for the easy task the rich and the
poor do pretty much the same
the hard task compared to the easy to
pass does nothing for the rich
because essentially uh the performance
is the same or like slightly different
but not statistically significantly so
and for the poor there's a large drop in
performance um
compared to the rich any questions on
that
okay so then um i'm going to show you
the second study that
uh is related to this so one thing you
might sort of say well as we already
showed you already a study so why did we
need another study whether we did one we
showed you that like
um poverty is thinking about poverty
affects people's cognition so why would
it
why do we need more evidence
that's right so effort is an interesting
issue that um
so there's in fact uh this study has um
and i took this out of the slides
because i have too many
um there's an incentivized version of
this task and uh the authors do find
that he wants to incentivize
these tasks uh uh do you find the same
patterns
but even there you know the it's a bit
sort of like a task that is not a task
that people do in their real life
and in a way which is actually not what
the harvest study is
addressing um the uh
you might wonder kind of does this
translate into real world choices and
decisions
that are actually of consequence for
people's behaviors
to be clear these effects here these
differences in cognitive performances
are very large this is like the order of
nineteen something like 10 iq points
which is really huge
um so you might sort of argue that you
know you think that iq etc matters a lot
so in some sense
uh that's what and shift but you know i
agree with you in some sense we would
like to see
does this translate into real world
choices that
um uh we see in every day
in people's everyday lives um
now i think we talked about a few of
those things so one is
external validity concerns which is to
say like look we did like to study
um in the mall which is a little bit of
funny thing to do
and like you hear about the scenario
which is kind of weird and maybe it
tricks you out and maybe the poor are
more freaked out than the rich
for some reason and like but really um
if you think about like paying back your
your debt or like any sort of school
fees or just not having money
that's like a repeated exposure of
something that you know in your real
life like for example not having harvest
versus harvest is the thing that you
experience every year or i'll be like
twice a year even and so you think you
know some of these things might sort of
go away with repeat exposure
and so we kind of would like to have
like a real world setting where like
we have actually really natural
variation or or some experimental
variation potentially
as opposed to like the somewhat weird um
uh feature in like some walls somebody
talks you up and asks you some questions
uh which people might find funny and
might not be representative for what
people do with their lives
um and then the second part is kind of
how do we interpret magnitudes right
so i showed you and said like look uh
these effects are really large
um after the hard task the poor do worse
than the rich
but we have like no idea how we should
scale this in terms of like
you know what does it actually mean for
our actual effects of poverty
like if you suppose i give somebody a
thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars
what does it do to people's performance
it essentially what this shows is that
the poor are more sort of frazzled by
these financial questions
but it gives you essentially and it
seems to be important because the
magnitude is large in these effects
but there's no way to actually scale
these effects in some sense and thinking
about like what does this
priming intervention actually correspond
to in the real world in terms of like
dollars or how rich or poor people
are so that's another sort of reason why
you might want to do
another study okay so what is the other
study
um as lauren was somebody saying it's
it's a study with 464
uh sugarcane farmers in 54 um villages
in tamil nadu
these are small scale farmers that earn
at least um the majority of sixty
percent of income
from um sugar cane so these are mostly
schwokin farmers
um and sort of crucially for the study
the um
harvest is staggered over three to five
months period set
by the sugar mills due to capacity
constraints so it's not that some people
um harvest earlier
than others because they decide to do so
maybe because they need more cash
but it's rather because of capacity
constraints the sugar male is
essentially
deciding who decides who
harvest um and who are asleep and so now
what the study exploit is that the
sugarcane harvest um cycle takes about
18 months
it's extremely long and as a result
um farmers tend to be a relatively poor
um pre-harvest this is kind of like
think about this is like
um you know grad school or undergrad
stipends if you have gotten money for
the month so for the semester or the
like
the beginning of the semester is always
amazing you have lots of or
months for that matter is always amazing
they have lots of cash and um
can do lots of nice things and then
towards the end of the
month or semester people tend to run out
of um
cash at least when i was a grad student
um
or student in general similar things are
true
um for like food stamps or other sort of
cash programs
there's quite a bit of evidence that
shows at the beginning of the months
people are doing
a lot better than at the end which sort
of seems to suggest that
people have trouble uh smoothing their
um
income over time which presumably has to
do with some form of self-control or
other problems
but so for the purpose of the study
farmers are relatively poor pre-harvest
and that now allows the authors to look
at
within personal comparisons of people
sometimes when they're poor and
sometimes when they're rich
at looking at their cognitive
performance by looking at people pre and
post
harvest now first you want to kind of
like
um see some evidence that farmer's
financial situation is actually worse
pre-harvest
and so there's quite a few um and
focused on the first column here
quite a few um pieces of evidence people
are more likely to have their belongings
um
pawned um they're more likely to have
loans outstanding
they also have more loans outstanding um
then also more likely to say
um yes to the question or higher
higher scores to the question about
their uh uh
uh ability to cope with ordinary um
bills
in the um uh past 15 days
and so uh post harvest and so so all of
these things that i was saying
essentially
before harvest people or farmers are
like in a financially
tricky situation and after harvest that
gets better because they get essentially
a bunch of cash
from this harvest because essentially
it's a cash crop you sell you sugarcane
and then you get a bunch of money that
you can use over the next
18 months now then the authors find
again using raven's matrices and some
measures of cognitive control
that people are doing a lot worse
pre-harvest compared to post-harvest
in terms of ravens matrices this is a
pure accuracy essentially people
do better that like getting more raven's
managers these cracks
compared to the control group um
they're also doing better in terms of
cognitive control
uh post harvest response times go down
which is a good thing
here and um post harvest also like
people's errors go down in these
measures
there's a lot of detail related to that
but in some sense uh
that doesn't matter much for you right
now people
essentially are doing better um post
harvest when they have
more cash now what
compounds can you think about what what
what are the potential problems for this
result
like surely this is consistent with uh
poverty impeding cognitive function but
there could be other things going on and
what are these other things
um i think there's some good evidence or
some one good thing is that like
it's it would have to be like a very
specific jaw shocked it has to do with
harvest because there's essentially the
harvest period was staggered over
several months so it's not like like you
know
at some point the weather got worse and
the weather got better because some
people actually harvested earlier than
others and there's a pre-post comparison
but
you know there could be other stuff time
friends or something going on at least
in some
some ways in a way i think uh uh a
confluent or
in a way it's also just like a different
interpretation perhaps in some ways in
the sense of saying like well it's not
just
worries about the level of income but
it's also
worries about essentially risk or
anxiety essentially and so that's
slightly different
but that anxiety would also sort of
capture people's minds in some ways
[Music]
of course then you would want to see
something like maybe that's worse for
the rich compared to the poor or things
like that but that's exactly right so
there could be essentially
labor costs or any sort of other
distractions related to
the hard rest which which this is kind
of related to what mania was saying
which is like the harvest itself
might have these kinds of um
effects okay i think we mentioned most
of the things that i have on my list
so uh so there's a first one is calorie
consumption which is sort of the typical
thing that development economist
economists could study a lot which is to
say you know uh
poor nutrition um might sort of make
people
worse it's bad for attention you talked
a little bit about like you know
shopping on a hungry stomach but also
think about like doing
tests or exams and on your stomach is
probably not a good empty stomach it's
probably not a good idea
the authors have some evidence that like
the
food expenditures are pretty similar
premium post harvest from like some
other sample
um overall malnutrition doesn't seem to
be like a huge
uh issue in this area and having said
that i think it's
also reasonable to think that like
pre-imposed harvest would you should
have actually more money and then
you've got to spend the money on
something and presumably some of that
will go on food but anyway so the
authors argue that
nutrition is not a big issue then um
there's sort of two broad issues with i
think was um joseon's and um
catherine's comments which is about the
uncertainty of the hardest size
and some issues related to labor effort
and so here the authors have some
evidence from
a post-harvest pre-payment sample what
does that mean this is a sample that
these are people who have um already
harvested already so they've already
exerted the labor effort and they also
know already their
approximate payment and
so i was getting confused by this um but
so these are people who have already
done their harvest they have already
they have done all the work already they
know already what the harvest size will
be like
but those people um essentially are
still
not doing better compared to the people
who have received their cash
so that essentially is to say like uh
even once you've done all the effort and
so on
um that doesn't seem to um
uh uh uh help in the sense of you're not
fully doing you're not exhausted from
the work already
you already have all your harvest there
you already know how big your harvest is
but you never actually you haven't
really received the money yet
um and you know already what the harvest
size is you can't believe you have the
anxiety of the harvest size
yet if you compare those people to the
people that received the money uh you
should still see differences between uh
those people and the people who are done
already
the harvest and so that sort of that
argues that essentially
um it's not about
anxiety per se about the harvest size
but
rather about like just having money in
your pocket um
versus not um let me see what the
this the correct graph
i see so this is a little bit
misleadingly um labeled what this is
supposed to say is like
this is post-harvest and pre-harvest but
what they mean by post-harvest and
pre-iris post-hybrid is meant by like
you have have received the cash versus
not
but both of these are actually both post
harvests in the senate they have been
already the
um uh uh the work
anyway sorry that's a bit confusing but
essentially um uh
what they're trying to say is
essentially what really matters is like
not
uh uh the work around the harvest per se
or the uncertainty around the harvest
it's really about like
receiving the cash um versus not and
then there's like another
um a problem which you haven't really um
brought up which is the issue of
learning effects right
when people do the tasks like um um
several times because
we do a test twice you gotta do better
and
you know um but to address this issue
they also have like what they call like
a hold out sample that takes the cargo
test for the first time
post harvest so what i what i showed you
before it was proposed
for both people i've done both of these
tests there's some samples only done
um the tasks like once post harvest and
they don't perform worse than
people who do the tasks for the second
time which seems to say like it's not
really about learning
having said that that is essentially
only like a small sub sample
comparison really seems um mostly
underpowered and
there are some concerns surely about
still um
any questions on these
okay um
so then um so this is a study from like
a few years ago so then
you know what kind of follow-up is there
um
uh that that sort of considers further
evidence
so there's one very nice study by
carvalho um in 2015
that looks at the same issue in the us
and
they looked at cognition and decision
making of u.s households and
um uh paydays and essentially they find
no cognitive effects whatsoever they
also find no effects
on decision-making uh uh as one would
have expected
raises the question about what's going
on here
um and what's going on so it could be
that this is an external
issue in some sense in a sense this
really what what is needed here is
really like extreme poverty and like
really large differences in my people's
income
or like the amount of money that i have
available and sort of
uh when you look at u.s households at
least the households that were
considered considered in the kanawha you
study around paydays where there's
differences in how much money they have
cash on hand they have
the difference is actually not that huge
and so that might just be not
sufficiently much expiration uh around
those paydays to be able to generate
those types of
um effect it could also be that these
effects don't really um
uh uh replicate in a sense of like
there's a replicability issue which
uh uh could be a concern as well
there's a nice study and this gets to
the issue that i think um
jose mentioned which is uh a study by
lee
is um uh looking at drought insurance
and what they essentially argue is that
uh when you put up with insurance so
usually
insurance for people would argue
insurance is used for if a bad
state happens in the world you can
essentially get my get a payment right
if i get some health shock or when my
harvest is bad or the like
i get some money from the insurance
company and that is good
because in the bad state of the marginal
utility is really high of receiving
money
and sort of i willing to pay for
insurance right now
in the future uh receiving
so i'm willing to pay for insurance now
because in the future
in a bad state of the world i value that
money more um than in a good state of
the world
so in a good state it's willing to pay
for insurance
now what lushan denmany instead arguing
is well there's an additional value of
insurance which essentially it's helping
reduce their anxiety and worries about
money ex-ante in all states of the world
that is to say
if i'm really worried about like bad
harvest shocks or other stuff
health shocks happening in the future
that might really frazzle me and really
sort of worry me all the time which
in turn might affect people's cognitive
performance well
that's in all states of the world even
when you're doing well right now
and even if nothing bad ever happens
you're gonna do worse today
because you know you're worried about
these things and sort of providing
insurance
therefore might help people do better
even in good states of the world or in
all states of the world in addition to
sort of having the insurance value of
helping people in bad state of the world
they don't have
some evidence of that there's some mixed
evidence overall but i think the idea of
like
insurance being helpful for the poor for
anybody um not just
because it helps in bad states but it
helps people worry about bats is a very
nice one that
hopefully will be explored um further
now then another question uh um i think
jose was bringing up is to say well
there are these cognitive tasks well i
showed you so far that these tasks and
like raven's matrices and cognitive
control
and sort of arguably iq tests are
important and helpful and sort of you
know
we think that's helpful and it maps with
something useful for the world
but it's a little bit hard to tell like
does this actually matter for income is
it this is really important or not
important and how much does it
um um so in a paper with
uh a good core
um we looked at this in a field setting
with workers
in um orisa and rural uh in rural areas
in
india and what we did there is we
hired people for about two weeks um to
do a simple
um labor task where they were doing uh
leaf plates was essentially like
um uh putting together leaves and chip
plates
uh which are sort of used in many
settings
by stitching them together using like
little uh wooden sticks
and um so people are hired for two weeks
and then for
um the sample we buried um when some
people were paid
earlier often some people heard later
were paid later
so everybody was paid exactly the same
conditional on showing up
and conditional on how much they
produced so their piece rates how much
they were paid were the same and their
attendance paid for showing up
the only difference was that some people
were paid earlier and some people were
paid later so that allows us then to
look at
how do people the same people how do
they perform
when they're ready versus not
compared to another group that is
essentially only paid
later and this is a period in the moline
period when people are extremely
financially constrained
so people are really short in cash so
you can look at essentially
uh really at the impact of transfers
uh or cash constraints in this setting
what we find is a relatively clear
evidence that paying people early makes
people
a lot more productive and moreover these
effects are the largest for the poorest
workers so essentially when you sort of
divide the sample into
uh among the people who are richer and
poorer to start with people who are
particularly poor
have the largest impacts um in this
sample and these are sort of pretty
large effects it's about five to ten
percent of the productivity
which is you know it doesn't sound that
large in absolute terms but in relative
terms or
in terms of like when you double
people's wages people's um
earnings go up only um as much or or not
much more
so really increasing people's
productivity is very very hard in these
settings
and relatively minor interventions such
as the one that we did
um had pretty large effects in the real
world setting for people for whom this
is really
uh the real jobs in the real life um for
about
two weeks so suppose you hired somebody
for a year
should you pay them like daily weekly
monthly
or or or what and so what am
i doing or what our evidence shows that
when you hire people for two weeks
paying people twice as i'm like paying
people um once after a week and then the
rest at the end
makes workers more productive than
paying workers only at the very end
um and assuming you know depending on
like the interest rate but that seems to
be like a thing the company should do
now but of course if you hire people for
like
a year then paying people weekly versus
monthly or
bi-weekly uh the comparison becomes
quite different because essentially the
control group that's paid after
two weeks now after two weeks of course
they have a lot more money
um because they haven't spent it
compared to the treatment group who's
paid
earlier and um i think there essentially
we can't believe this is we can't really
speak to that in some sense our our
design is just not really
uh uh set up to do this you would have
to do at least you know you would have
to do
uh at least another week or two to
measure how the control group now doing
compared to the treatment group or like
do it repeatedly there might also be
some effects on like
uh over time repeatedly some of these
effects might be going away because
workers learn and so on and so forth um
i think of this evidence much more
sense of proof of concept that a
providing cash or alleviating cash
constraints among workers
either through some low interest rate
loans or some early payments
or some form of like ubi or cash
transfers unconditional
additional cash transfers essentially
improving workers financial situation in
some ways
can be productive for firms um now how
the firm plan actually does that
we don't necessarily know and this is
sort of too small of a short of an
experiment
uh to show that but it's sort of proof
of concept that in a real world setting
with very high stakes for workers is
there like real earnings
there seem to be these uh uh effects so
for firms it might be wealthy
to in fact try to improve their uh
actual situation
um or for governments it might be
valuable
uh to think about cash transfers as a
way to
so usually when you think about cash
transfers let me actually
talk about this for a second and then we
can talk about other compounds of the
study
so usually when you think about the
public debate about cash transfers and
about sort of like welfare programs for
the poor
often sort of the right-wing response is
like well the poor are going to be lazy
and they're not going to work and
they're like you know
um what about effort and so on and so
forth and they get used to the money and
then they
don't work hard enough eventually well
the evidence that we have here
in our paper seems to say in fact the
opposite that is to say
uh workers when you alleviate the
financial constraints when you give them
cash to become
more productive and they work harder
than um
otherwise granted we don't have any
labor supply response what i'm showing
you here is essentially productivity
which is you know
how hard a worker is working or how much
our workers producing per
hour work but i think similar things
could be due for
two for cash transfers and there's some
quite interesting evidence on cash
transfer
programs so both cash transfer
and um in particular um what's called
ultra poor programs which is sort of
these
uh multi-faceted uh asset programs
leads to large and sustained increases
in assets savings consumptions etc
that is to say once you provide people
um with financial resources when they're
very poor
not only do they better in the short run
but in the case of the outdoor poor
programs in the long run
three to five years later people are
doing better in terms of like
having more assets saving more consuming
more um
and so on um and that seems to say that
uh there might be some things an issue
going on
some form of like a poverty trap going
on and sort of some of the underlying
potential channels might be things like
scarcity stress
mental health and so on i'm going to
talk a little bit about mental health
and stress
in a second but essentially if there are
these types of effects going on
for the government or any other sort of
public policy
um these kinds of programs conditional
language conditional cash transfers
um have in addition to having the
advantage of like you know improving
people's well-being and
having like high you know marginal uh uh
you're telling your money when they're
very poor
it might also in addition make people
more productive uh as opposed to like
you know working less
um or um the like so i think those two
things i think are sort of
um um uh uh the the takeaways
if one wanted to understand optimal pace
structures one would have to do longer
longer and types of experiments as
natalie um
uh pointed out so there's essentially
the way we set this up is um we
essentially
people i'm sorry this is my slack uh
pay people to um
uh people through the employer
essentially said okay the employer is
paying you now earlier versus later
and naturally then the worker might just
happier doing better financially but
also like like the employer better say
like look you just paid me early
and i trust you more that you're going
to be paid me in the future maybe that's
some form of gift giving a reciprocity
i'm sort of happy about harder um to
make the employer happy
several things to get at this and the
most important part perhaps we also have
like
uh we announce essentially the structure
a few days before the actual payment is
made that is to say on day five we
announce and say on day eight
you're going to be paid versus we don't
announce so you say you're going to be
paid only later
at the end of the study and so if you
think you know this is about
reciprocity or like um people being
feelings towards the employer
you would think that then workers should
then already be working harder
once they're here about when they get
these kind of announcement um effects
and it seems to be the case that there's
essentially no announcement effect
whatsoever
uh work uh only become productive
uh pretty much precisely once they've
received their uh
cash on hand which is very much
consistent with what i showed you
earlier uh
the results from money adele um in their
study
it seems to really be the case that
knowing that somebody will be paid
is really not helping workers both from
like or making
workers more productive both in the form
of
their relationship or due to their
relationship with the employer but
also due to um
uh other effects including uh
sort of like perhaps their their worries
or concerns that they might have about
so it seems to me that similarly from
the money adult
uh paper so like when workers are
have done their harvest and you have the
harvest in front of you
and you know it's worth so many rupees
uh that doesn't seem to increase their
cognitive scores that's what i was
showing you earlier really what it seems
to be is like you have to be actually
paid so once workers
actually have the cash in hand only then
the cognitive function goes up
uh there seems to be something about
this this
example i have for you is like suppose
you have to pay your bills suppose
you're like sort of like don't have
enough money and then you know on the
first the months you're going to be paid
your stipend or whatever
as a student there's something uh uh
distinctly different from
having actually been paid the money on
your bank account and having it
uh in your possession that is yours or
being sent a check or whatever
as opposed to knowing it's going to come
in two days and you have your
outstanding credit card bills
even if you know that you can pay them
that's in something from introspection
the best example i have for you
but it seems to be and then be right in
some sense there could have been some
effects of just telling workers should
be gonna be paid early versus later
but it doesn't seem to be the case it
really seems to be the case of like
receiving the money having cash in hand
and then being able to pay the money
lender or pay or essentially some
uh person that you owe money some money
back seems to be what's quite important
for generating those kinds of events
okay so let's move on
um i already talked about this
essentially yeah so there seems to be
these large effects
of uh uh ultra poor programs which
seem to say that there might be some um
underlying behavioral
or other poverty trap going on and sort
of we don't have the answer to that but
one hypothesis is that some of the
underlying
psychological issues might be
responsible
for that now what are other
poverty so poverty entails a bunch of
different deprivations beyond money
including malnutrition higher levels of
stress
sleep deprivation people's sleeping
conditions tend to be terrible
uh noise pollution uh the poor more
disproportionately
exposed to noise there's environmental
pollution
in particular sort of air that the poor
are much more exposed to
heat the poor often don't have access to
um
or heat or temperature more generally
the poor heat poor
uh have uh are more exposed to high
temperature and don't have access to acs
often
there's also some form of like stigma
and exclusion which might have certain
cognitive and other effects
um there's some evidence of
disproportional
uh disproportionate substance abuse that
showed you some
evidence of increased
excessive drinking and there's also
quite a bit of evidence of uh increased
mental
uh illness among especially uh among the
poor so
within any given location the poor are
disproportionately affected by
mental illness including things like
depression and anxiety
but there's a bunch of research in other
settings that shows that
these factors each of these factors
affect either health and or cognitive
function and so you might wonder you
know how are these factors then
affecting people's um
decision making and choices and just to
give you some example of this there's
some work that we have done in
in chennai i also like to do some sense
of what this looks like uh the poor
essentially tend to have very very
challenging sleeping conditions
there's dust noise mosquitoes people
sleep in the same room people sleep
outside
in the middle of the street and it is
it's hot
as people sleep on the floor so
essentially any challenging sleeping
condition that you can think of you can
find it among the urban poor so one
question you might ask us well then
does um this lack of sleep of good sleep
it affect people's
capacity to work on their decision
making and so in our study what we do is
we objectively measure sleep
quantity and quality in chennai and
today document severe sleep deprivation
and alarmingly
low um quality of sleep in this setting
what do i mean by this
people sleep on average about 6.5 hours
per night
and the quality of their sleep is low um
which is
uh one measurement that of that is like
their uh
fraction of time their sleep uh among
the fraction of
the time that they spend in bed is about
70 that's what's referred to as like
sleep efficiency
sleep efficiency is um way higher in
which country it's about
85 to 90 so if the rich spend like
an hour in bed they spend about like 55
or something minutes uh
asleep if the poor do that um it's about
uh 40 something minutes so essentially
there's lots of awakenings
and as a consequence in our sample
people sleep about like five and a half
hours
um per night now then uh what we do is
we have two interventions to increase
sleep
we provide people information sleep
devices um
and sort of uh which is like mattress
earplugs eye shades and so on
and we increase sleep by quite a bit for
about um three weeks and then this
experiment
we also have an intervention as an avid
dimension that offers people naps at the
office
which increases both or provides like
high quality and high
quality of sleep in that setting now
what we find then is um somewhat
surprisingly that actually increasing
people's night sleep does
very little so like people sleep about
like you know 20 to 30 minutes more
every night for three weeks
and they measure the labor supply we
hire them for about that time
people are not doing better in any way
in terms of like people not working more
people are not more productive people
are not doing better in cognitive tasks
they're not happier
and so on and so forth they also don't
make different decisions
and if anything you know they decrease
their labor supply they actually work
fewer hours why is that well because
people are spending so much more time in
bed
um they have less time available during
the day and some of that time goes into
like working
a few hours um now in contrast an app
treatment um has pretty large effects on
the productivity attention well-being
patients and so on
so it's not like sleep cannot affect
people's outcomes in these settings
but rather night sleep as it is does not
really do very much
at least the type of night sleep that
people are getting
and so what we then sort of um uh
provide some evidence of that like
what's really important here are the
reason why people's
sleep does not do very much in
increasing their
productivity or improving their outcomes
is because the quality of sleep is so
low
so when we sort of look at the sample
and look at like people who sleep better
and worse at baseline at the beginning
of the study
people who sleep better at the beginning
of the study they actually tend to have
reasonably large effects on
their productivity and contrast people
who have
bad sleep to start with like for them
essentially increasing their sleep does
nothing and potentially makes things
um worse so what did we i do not want
you to take away that like sleeping does
not do anything
uh and my t students are chronically
undersleeping and you could be probably
sleeping uh uh more both all of you or
most of you
essentially what what we learned from
this is that when people's sleep
conditions are really terrible
well then um increasing um
increasing one's sleep actually doesn't
do very much the return on sleeping is
just very very low
and so what you learn in some ways that
the poor at least in this
setting the poor are actually doing um
as well as they could in a sense that
they do the best they can
and since sleep is so bad or so terrible
people sleep really badly
um increasing their sleep does not do
very much
that's not to say like if you actually
fix their sleeping conditions if you
put everybody into like a nice hotel or
a nice bedroom and or give them like a
nice house
and help them sleep better that wouldn't
have potentially large effects
but the study that we are we conducted
was not doing that study that we
conducted was essentially saying like
take your sleep conditions as given
and look at what happens when you
increase people's um sleep duration for
given um sleep quality and that doesn't
do very much
in contrast as i showed you um or i told
you naps
seem to be quite effective in having a
large a number for
range of effects which seems to say that
like um sleep can potentially matter
quite a bit
but what really is important is try to
figure out how could we perhaps increase
people's sleep quality
which might have an important event so
that was a lot of information more than
i perhaps intended
any questions on that
okay so then the last um piece which i'm
gonna just sort of um
say a little bit about is um a paper
um that we just finished on the
relationship between poverty and mental
uh uh common mental disorders as they
refer to which is
anxiety and depression and
um what we there sort of argue and uh
it's a pretty short paper
if you're interested um put it on my
website um tonight
um we're gonna look at uh we're looking
at essentially the relationship between
poverty and these two conditions um and
what we do is first we show the causal
effect in both directions
and so there's quite a bit of evidence
that essentially uh
being poor is bad for people's mental
health these are like causal studies so
for example
providing people cash transfers improves
consistently their mental health
so there's a causal effect of not from
not having money on people's mental
health and anxiety and depression
at the same time there's a causal effect
of anxiety and depression
on people's ability to earn
income and thus their poverty
so for example if you provide people
with cbt or some other forms of
psychotherapy that improves their uh uh
reduces their
depression and then in turn it increases
their labor supply
which in turn uh presumably increases
their ability to earn
income so there's causal effects in both
directions from poverty to
common mental disorders and from
continental disorders to
poverty and then what the paperwork does
in a lot more detail is then think about
what are different mechanisms for
this causal relationship and what
exactly what evidence do they actually
have
of that and so on the on the side from
poverty from economic conditions to
mental health
there's a number of different um issues
that could be quite important
ranging from like stresses or just being
exposed to lots of shocks and therefore
um worries and uncertainty to
environmental conditions in particular
there's quite a bit of emerging evidence
of pollution being bad for people's
mental health
so essentially pollution causing
depression for example
um there's some uh potential for
physical health just being in bad health
might sort of bad
it might be bad for your mental health
in part because it causes physical pain
and other illnesses uh
there's some evidence of early life
conditions so being
uh uh growing up in poverty tends to be
bad for people's mental health and
there's some nice evidence of
um shocks to people's uh to mother's
father's income
uh might cause uh uh uh mental illness
much later in life for the children
um there's quite a bit of evidence of
trauma violence and crime with which the
poor are disproportionately exposed to
affecting people's mental health and
finally social status shame and
isolation if you sort of like stigmatize
and like uh
isolate from society that might be bad
for your mental health
particular sort of relative comparisons
could be quite important
and then at the same time uh there are
effects in the other directions coming
from uh
depression and anxiety um so one
profound way in which
uh depression and anxiety affect
people's um behaviors cognitive function
the way people think
so in contrast to other things such as
health um uh
depression anxiety affect the way people
think including their and then that
might sort of affect people's beliefs
their confidence over confidence under
confidence belief
updating all the stuff that we talked
about in the class as well as their
preferences their time purposes
risk preferences social preferences and
so on
it might affect their labor productivity
uh and their labor so apply how much
people work on how productive they are
of course um uh people might be very
stigmatized and treated badly
um uh because of mental illness which in
in addition sort of then um uh uh makes
people less likely to
seek help potentially because you know
if you're then stigmatized
you might not want to declare to your
employer to anybody else
that you're depressed people tend to
have worse health conditions
um if they're depressed or if they
suffer from mental illness or other
health conditions tend to get worse
health expenditures
there's also some evidence of uh
depression affecting
uh women's empowerment i think there's
two potential channels here
uh one is that women are in fact
disproportionately
by uh depression anxiety and so on so
like the prevalence is
the measured prevalence is about twice
as high um
and so you know to the extent that now
you if you improve people's
um mental health uh
women will disproportionately benefit
from that
and then there's evidence that once you
do that uh women have
a higher bargaining power in the
household um
uh uh more say about resources spent and
so on
and so forth and then finally uh
potentially quite important
is effects on young people this ranges
from like
primary and secondary schooling to like
college students
and so on which is to say that a lot of
mental health conditions
appear during adolescence and so those
are often when very critical decisions
are made when it comes to education like
do you drop out of school
you go to college and so on and so forth
um it turns out there's actually quite
uh not not a lot of causal evidence on
this but it seems very plausible that
this could be um quite important instead
of taking these things together it seems
to me that poverty
through like various different channels
including scarcity which i should be at
the beginning
but also including all these other
conditions might affect profoundly
and how they make decisions and how
productive they are at work
which then could reinforce uh uh uh
poverty and make it harder for people to
become richer um this is a lot of
information so any questions
uh i'm happy to discuss or answer any
questions that you would have
i'm not expecting you to remember all of
those things i was just
more elaborating for anybody who might
be interested you can also read
all of these things and the paper um uh
i'll add to the course website
as well
all right so um on wednesday we're going
to talk about happiness and mental
health
um please read the paper by kahneman
notices i just changed this in the
syllabus so if you have an old version
of the syllabus
please make sure you read the new paper
the paper is very short so it shouldn't
be uh
tricky to read essentially it's looking
at what are what is
what kinds of things uh predict whether
people are happy
uh or or not and then on monday we're
going to talk about
uh policy with with um uh behavioral
agents just as a reminder we'll have a
guest um
at the end of class uh next time i hope
um the guest will come at 220. i'm
hoping for a um
llama to visit us but it could also be a
goat um we'll see how that
goes any questions or comments
when it comes to depression anxiety
specifically let me talk about more
generally
so one of the things i'm working on for
example is look at
looking at the impact of cognitive
variable therapy or other psychotherapy
is to improve
people's mental health and then look at
the effects on people's beliefs
how confident are they in themselves um
how they update their beliefs and
remember we had this stuff on like from
ireland brow and others about like
asymmetric belief updating
and is that affected for example by
people's mental health
moreover we look at preferences which is
precisely time preferences social
preferences risk preferences
and you know once you approve people's
depression
does that affect people's uh time social
interest
preference more broadly um there's quite
a few people trying to do studies and i
went over this fairly quickly
uh to look at these kinds of uh uh types
of effects
which for example um there's some work
on malnutrition that shows like once you
provide people with more uh
calories there's some uh indications
of like less discounting which is kind
of what you're
uh uh what you're alluding to uh there's
some work on like the relationship
between stress and discounting there's
actually not that much evidence or less
evidence than you would expect
for sleep deprivation for example we
find when you when people nap they're
less present biased
compared to when they haven't mapped
i find for example for outdoor
consumption i do find that people save
more and it seems to be not driven by
having more money so again that seems to
be consistent with people's time
preferences in some way affected by
these conditions
um overall there's quite a bit of
evidence so far on
productivity so papers essentially show
that when you're disproportionately
exposed by to heat
people are less productive people learn
less when you're exposed to noise people
are less productive
when people are have less nutrition
they're less productive
and so on and so forth um there's less
evidence so far on decision making and
sort of preferences overall
that's what people are currently working
on that is exactly the question can be
sort of explained potentially
some of the stuff that i was mentioning
at the very beginning of the lecture
can explain potentially certain
behavioral biases or certain
deviations from the neoclassical model
by
alleviating some of the or addressing
some of the psychological
um we have don't have a lot of evidence
and we hope to have some more um
but that's exactly what people are
working on
you